since being sworn into office joe biden
has had a lot of challenges facing his
presidency
and as you'd guess not everyone is happy
with how he's meeting them
for more about that please welcome the
host of the popular conservative podcast
the right truth mr darren tooth
welcome to the show darren thanks for
having me conan i appreciate the chance
to address what is shaping up to be the
worst
presidency in american history okay well
already that feels a little strong
darren why do you say that
where do i start conan with biden as
president we have
6.7 unemployment okay
we got an impeachment trial right around
the corner and we got the highest
covet death rate in the world and that
number is going up
every day yeah okay fair enough but how
can you attribute all that to biden he's
only been president for
two weeks exactly and if biden can do
that much damage in two weeks
imagine what the next four years are
going to be like you know what
better yet don't imagine it unless you
want to puke all right all right that's
that's being a little dramatic okay oh
is it is it dramatic to love my country
conan
how am i supposed to tuck my two
beautiful children
atlas and shrugged into bed every night
and tell them that they're safe
when i'm struggling not to barf my
brains out because there's a fence
around the white house
okay you know what i can feel a little
bit of puke in the back of my head
no no no no you're going to that's
ridiculous listen we get it
we get that you're upset there's a fence
around the white house
but the fence is there because trump
supporters have been threatening
violence
let's look at the facts conan fact
biden promised change and yet tom brady
is in the super bowl again
fact biden promised to protect the
african-american community
and yet we've already lost cecily tyson
and hank aaron what is he planning now
okay those people
were i'm sad that they're gone but it
had not
fact stop interrupting i just saw a
story the other day about some people
that found a bear swimming in their hot
tub
is that what joe biden's america is
gonna look like because i don't know
if i can handle that i'm gonna get sick
no no you're not gonna get sick that's
ridiculous don't get i'm not getting
sick
right this second but i could easily i
don't have a false alarm no
that was a burp darren that's ridiculous
uh first of all you're not gonna throw
up and second bears in hot tubs
have nothing to do with biden's
competence as a president i mean you
have to admit you're really stretching
why do i keep seeing photos of bernie
sanders just sitting around in his
mittens doing nothing
he's on the subway he's in a hockey
penalty box
he's goofing off in the waiting room
from the movie beetlejuice
how's he supposed to pass a coveted
relief bill when he's hanging out with
beetlejuice
it makes me sick stop doing that makes
me
sick thing it's ridiculous and those are
memes you're talking about it's a meme
don't you know what a meme is atlas
get the bucket daddy's talking about the
presidency again
and darren i realize you have your
political biases all right and you need
to keep your conservative audiences
happy but listen joe biden is entering
office
facing extraordinary challenges so why
don't we all just give him
a little time to enact his agenda before
he completely tear down his presidency
you know what that's a fair point and i
gotta say
thank you what you just said about biden
really makes me think a lot
i'm glad to hear that it makes me think
a lot about blowing chunks all over my
podcast studio
this is stupid when did i have cheerios
coast is clear all right uh no it's not
oh it's like a shoelace or something i
don't know when i ate a shoe
i'm not buying any of it and i'm playing
one you know going again you're going to
go again
get on something else you good i'm empty
all right
what a what a wonderful segment
now i'm empty okay what came up that
time
your old haircut all right listen